on a fait autre chose
j'ai demandé au pianiste de préparer un
certain nombre de chansons de morceaux
il va vous les jouez et alors ça va vous
évoquez quelque chose ariel et vous
allez donner votre avis ou répondre aux
questions que ces morceaux pause ça
s'appelle l'interview piano
alors s'il vous plaît maestro premier
morceau
[Musique]
johnny johnny ma gueule oui ma
alors quoi ma gueule qu'est ce qu'elle a
ma gueule ouais qu'est ce que la vôtre
gueule écoutez
c'est une moi je dois dire déjà que
johnny
comme tous les français je les aime
beaucoup et ça donne aussi n'en parle de
la vôtre
et puis j'ai eu la chance de chanter une
fois avec johnny non non non non non au
parc des princes ben si si si et alors
je me rappelle jeux wii
vous la trouvez comment votre visage ce
qu'il faut c'est cesser mais
suffisamment pour ne pas être obsédé par
soit là
m
[Musique]
c'est par là
non non non non non je suis snob à je
suis cela oui souvent on me dit ça que
je le suis et moi vraiment je ne me sens
pas du tout snob non non maestro
e
comme d'habitude c'est my way ben ouais
ouais alors les habitudes ont mauvaise
presse on dit ah oui l'habitude tue
l'amour etc et moi je trouve que les
habitudes si ce qui est plus de
délicieux dans la vie si on l'avait pas
d'habitude qu'est-ce qu'on ne viendrait
prendre son bain c'est une merveilleuse
habitudes si vous en prenez six par jour
oui et puis l'habitude
mais l'habitude ya rien de mieux moi
j'ai quand j'ai l'habitude que que mon
mari rentre à la maison j'entends sont
pas j'ai l'habitude je le reconnais et
louve la clé de la porte j'ai l'habitude
d'attribuer encore de label
et puis le soir j'entends son souffle
sur l'oreiller
gélatine
habitué de versailles j'ai sauté dans
les
eaux continentales
on continue maistre
[Musique]
e
oh
jamais
bonjour
que tu m'aimes que tu as effectué oui
n'avoue jamais jamais
bon eh ben moi je trouve qu'il faut
avouer justement tu m'as pompiers damas
non non il faut avouer sans larmes
non mais écoutez il faut avouer son
amour genre je ne dis rien et c'est on
le fait on ne dit jamais assez de choses
tendre est gentil il faut avouer aux
gens qu'on les aime très bien dans l'air
est trop
une femme est une femme
non
avec une femme est bien
bon moi écouter je suis quelqu'un de
très sage mais
je trouve qu'il ya autant de sensualité
qui lie à d'individus et donc que les
gens préfèrent les femmes ou les hommes
où tous les deux et tout ça laisse pas
thierry et bien
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu